you
the human mind is an incredible thing
very trying to achieve its full
potential that needs a spark the spark
of inquiry excitement and passion off
that spark comes from a teacher however
difficult life can be teachers have
always been there behind the scenes
showing us the way forward
I was the easiest person to teach I was
slow to learn to read when my
handwriting was untidy but at the age of
14 my teacher
devran tada showed me how to harness my
energy and encouraged me to think
creatively about math he made me wonder
he made me furious he opened up new
worlds to me that is what a great
teacher can do
this is why I am a strong supporter of
the global teacher prize
thanks to sunny Varkey Havarti
foundation we need great teachers abroad
read minds or we will never solve the
world's most pressing problems it is
therefore my pleasure to announce the
top ten finalists of the global team
surprised 2016 VR and an hour up from
Palestine Achilles evening from Pakistan
Robin toe resilient remedial so feathery
from the USA call integrity from the UK
Richard Johnson from Australia I am
Muhammad from Kenya
mara drazi from Finland Michael saw
school from the USA
cuz I'll attack caste from Japan good
luck to each of them but thank you for
all the work they do